what we've been doing so far is taking a
Venn diagram that's already been made
and then trying to sort of extract
meaning out of it okay if you take
something and you're trying to
understand what it means we will after
that it's called interpretation so what
you've been doing is interpreting a Venn
diagram that's it handed to you and as
you can see that takes some careful
thought but it's doable like what's a
lot more challenging and therefore more
important it's not interpreting a Venn
diagram that has been handed to you but
getting a bunch of them for information
and then building the Venn diagram
yourself you have to take on the role of
constructing a Venn diagram with all
they hand you these words and some
numbers and I know that's hate you
some words numbers and we'll see if we
can construct a diagram so how are you
started you can write down some of this
issue why let's imagine we go to a
friend's and they all attended banquet
together then you get some information
about what the friends ate during the
banquet you've got seven to eight apple
pie
nine of them 15 a feast and the last
needs to finish engine runs right under
four is there was one one eight nine now
in a second I'm going to ask you a
question or a couple of versions
actually about this situation but to
start off we need to understand how can
I represent this information on a
vibrant thing now remember before when I
asked you to get that table I left a
little space blank on the bottom of tent
one of that inside I said hey I want you
to think about where that went Venn
diagrams the important tool to use
obviously they give you a Venn diagram
we need to use it but sometimes they
won't give you one and there's a clue
inside this question that tells you it's
kind of like the big red flag it's like
hey hey don't just do it list don't just
for an array run a new tree you really
need a Venn diagram
does anyone notice seven plus nine plus
one law such as is 17 right so there's
what people here apparently then have
the bank that so what actually have you
look at these that like in our original
Venn diagram clearly there must be some
people who did more than one thing does
that make sense right that's the only
way we can account for these extras that
seem to appear okay so underneath we've
got this information let's visualize
this by drawing like before we'll do it
blocks mercifully I'm not going to ask
you to draw three circles how many
circles do we need for this expression
to just - one of them is gonna represent
a pie
one of them is going to produce it beef
and you tell others hungry whatever I've
done this question okay so put your two
circles down conveniently one of the
things starts with a and one starts it B
so let's just label those for a second
now I'm speaking how we can piece this
together we've got all these numbers
here but I'm just gonna say to you right
out the game write some numbers it
easier to use than others for instance
see this number 12 right away you should
know I can't just write 12 anywhere on
the diagram right because 12 like this
number up here right 12 is what you
should get
after you add up all the numbers that
eventually will appear okay so I can't
use 12 yet have a look at the rest of
the information which of those do you
think might be the easiest to use okay
fantastic so you met me happen before we
said oh we're gonna stick you 10 and we
know they did take cut off straight so
they must be drawn the outside same time
with same wage with this guy right
this one just on the outside I know that
it's apple-pie don't be just like though
these numbers you okay so next I've got
to use before you decided this one is
kind of like last right I want to use
one of these numbers right so how do I
do that well if you've got 12 people
internal we've just become for one of
them right on the outside having well
left to fit somewhere there 11 left
right so there's 11 do you agree are
somewhere inside the circle so far so
good
that gives 11 inside the circles how
many people will be in this a circle or
together or the whole way so permanent
this should be seven right but if I know
there should be seven here and 11 in the
circles all together does that tell us
what this number outside in the a
circles which that bit that has to be is
the sodium sodium and is 11 in all of
the circles so what's missing if you've
got the seventh it's there
very good think back for a second I know
I'm gonna have 11 in here by the end I
know 7 have to be here underwear 7 on
but it is somewhere me other Ford only
can be here ok now we can actually start
to filling the rest of the information
there are 4 people here how many are the
rest of them who made big it should be 5
because you want 5 plus 4 equal money
and that gives you the last number
having Google and Apple PI over 2
because that 2 plus 5 gives you 7
do a quick check to slap a little as
well ok let me ask you two questions on
the basis of this number one if we you
know throw this down which it's simple
enough for me to post
for the recipe if you select any friend
at random what's appropriate the age if
I just say apple pie first almond eyes
include anyway this dr. Addison can you
are in circle so I would say that's out
of 12 if I were interested in just this
room thanks guys but we're interested in
the true the parents recognize how I
have to rephrase the question
very good I have to say probability of
I'm applying and the word only is what
tells you I'm Imogen concept what if I
asked you what's the probability of
someone eating but which place like was
that it's the fire frame and get has had
all same samples based on conditions
okay so if you return back to your
original table if you want to fill it up
right now let's have a think about it
right look at the numbers that you've
got look at what happens when you
represent this right the KT situation to
the donor when the Venn diagram is going
to be the way go if they don't give you
one yourself write it themselves
is that how look at the numbers how look
at the numbers in the situation with add
them up do they have some sort of like
contradiction today do not touch all to
be none that you have at the top that's
what you know there must be an over for
that at the word overlap hopefully Matt
like treaties for you Oggy near overlaps
are things with Venn diagrams and does
that make sense okay
lots of students they make these na-na
like pasado a tree diagram or array and
they kind of count for the fact that
there are people in two groups one true
branch to the tree simultaneously
becomes very confusing